hi I'm Evan Carmichael and welcome to
another edition of ask Evan in today's
video I'm going to answer question from
what my readers Jackie who asked what do
you think are the most important
personality traits in successful
entrepreneurs so I get asked this
question a lot and my answer isn't
normal I guess most people think to be a
successful entrepreneur you have to be
really good at sales so you have to be a
super genius and I've done really well
at school you have to have had a lot of
money at being the Wright family it's
really good at networking if you're
really good people and the fact is if
you look at successful entrepreneurs and
how they got started I've done a ton of
research on this most of those aren't
true some of them are really good at
sales some of them are some of they're
really genius inventors and a lot of
them are and a lot of you feel that at
school I didn't do well and so I
wouldn't attach any kind of worry to
that if you're not really good at sales
you don't think you're a genius inventor
you can still have a lot of success as
an entrepreneur what I've seen be
successful and what works are three main
things that every entrepreneur has gone
through that notice the first is that
you got started and a lot of people
think they have the next great idea they
wanted to be an entrepreneur but they
don't do anything about it right and you
have to take that leap you have to get
that jump you have to get started if you
want to be an entrepreneur even if it's
part-time small-scale whatever you're
taking small steps to move your business
forward and every entrepreneur did that
they overcame the fear they overcame
whatever pressure is the social
pressures apparently pressures that were
on them at the time and they got their
business started so that's step one step
two is you have to really have a passion
for what you're doing and if you look at
any successful entrepreneur you'll see
that they really cared about what they
were doing and they were so super
excited and passionate about it and that
passion helped drive them towards
building a successful
the ones to do it just for the money and
trying to get rich usually don't so make
sure that whatever you're doing you can
have a lot of value to it it really
excites you it gets your date going and
you want to just really go up and build
a successful company because you love
what you're doing
they ain't they up and step three is
they stuck with it it rarely works the
first time you make so many mistakes
what you think is gonna happen it
doesn't happen people you know give you
the wrong answer
and it's a lot harder to start a
business than most people think right
you have a lot of enthusiasm into at the
beginning and you have to have that
passion to help guide you through all
the roadblocks that you get a face but
successful entrepreneurs push through
all those roadblocks broke down all the
brick walls until they were able to
achieve that success you have to have
that motivation to what a keep on going
so verb entrepreneurs again my three
tips one get started you gotta have that
drive for one and actually launch your
business to make sure your superb
passionate about it and then three you
have to have the persistence and keep
going until you become a success I hope
that helps if you guys liked the video
please give it a thumbs up and it also
love to hear your thoughts and feedback
want to leave a comment below and stay
tuned to the next episode
you